hi herzlich willkommen zum heutigen
video leute ich hab ja letztens ein
video gemacht wurde geguckt habe wer
meine doppelgänger sind und werde ich
dieses video geplant habe mich auf eine
homepage gestoßen die heißt alex punkten
und was ist was ist das anhand von dem
was man ein stück heraus findet wenn ich
das da ähnlich aussieht und was bietet
sich in dem fall besser als die
doppelgänger von unseren youtube an
herauszufinden so da gehen wir jetzt mal
auf die homepage für gesellschaftlich
aktiv in den prozess von anwälten
illegale bilder und momente sofort
wieder richtig durch für jeden leicht
kriegt ihr nicht rechtskräftig dann
klicken view sauer sagt er übrigens auch
gerne mal auf jeder schon mal irgendwo
anders gesehen hat weil ich etwas
wirklich von jürgens geholt sondern
bleibt selbst aufgebracht sowie bienen
als allererstes mit internen apo med
weil ich gespannt wie man so auf die
apparate werden gleich sehen dass
bearbeitet wird
14 4 / ok zu fahren
10.35 uhr und findet man könnte schon
sagen dass sie sich in gewisser weise
ähnlich aussehen also sowie verweise sie
nicht es keinen wechsel muss ab dem
punkt geben das wetter aussieht aber sie
werden schon ähnlich und genau das heißt
du dass wegen dieser seite dass sie
tatsächlich gut funktioniert aber
genauer sein bis auch wirklich
sondern gucken erst an berta grace
doppelgänger rolle ist ein okay und er
macht anscheinend auch indische filme
mbh seiner vorschau wie immer man
zweites auto von herrn abgelehnt dass
ich glaube es ist immer schwierig wenn
das gewicht nicht frontal mit worden ist
und dann kommt wieder genau die gleiche
gedacht andere fotos komplett anders
bewertet werden aber abschreiben
ob ihr tatsächlich das beste zu reggie
mensch bisschen wird das neue kabarett
am meisten er ist wahr aber weiter mit
einem foto ihrer lieblingssängerin mit
der fantasy künstler aus dem
deutschsprachigen raum
[Musik]
na ja wobei als erstes gefällt hat auch
okay bin ich blond braun roter habe mal
davon absieht und einfach nur auf die
gesichtszüge schaut die nase in sich
einigermaßen die augen ähneln sich sehr
einfach die abstände und zufrieden und
was dem gewicht wenn ich schon recht
ähnlich also ganz zufrieden bin ich
damit aber nicht damit ist er der
favorit peter sodann hier entrichtet
generell was mir aufgefallen dass ist es
richtig schwierig ist frontale pose zu
finden weil dir so ein bisschen
wegschaut und post oder sowas aber zwei
tage konnten so die ah ja durch das
match kommen lassen will ich was mache
ich finde dass diese eine die hier unten
ist noch ein bisschen wenig auf die zwei
prozent unterschied menschen aber sie
sich schon wer in der siemens coli als
schauspielerin und als hörer für den
harry potter film sind jetzt mal dass
auch auf den anderen
aber das ist überhaupt nicht auf in den
harry potter filmen kann natürlich
erkennen mussten entweder fällig aber es
findet ewigkeit ist auf jeden fall da
also kann man sagen was man will
ein problem noch mal weiteres foto und
vielleicht noch ein besseres ergebnis
raus aber ich bin dafür bald auch hart
bearbeitet von der fiorentina ist eine
verspannte arbeitet mit mir ein bisschen
nach verletzungen aus aber ich schaue
ich dann als nächstes nehmen wir unseren
oder allerdings über julien beim in
deinem weihnachtsmann foto 46 prozent
das soll das gleiche mensch war der
stein ich habe die agb und die von vor
der natur aus harry potter der rechte
typ und ich finde manchmal so genau
hinschaut gut durch thomas vogel haben
wir auch so in der effektive aber zu dem
platz unterstützt und person bei den
analogen dani auch ähneln sich ein
bisschen unserer welt antritt umwelt so
als nähme stern
mit diesem foto ich finde es echt
erstaunlich die teilweise nur die
nahrung und wasser von ähnlichen und ja
auch so waren diese jennifer morrison
generell nicht gut also sag mal wenn ich
also oder es ist wirklich verdammt also
kann man sagen natürlich echt immer sind
zweiten mal kelly überspringe ich bin
schon zufrieden mit dem ergebnis aber er
hat mich viel geld sondern wir machen
natürlich der höchste bieter so nutzt so
geleistete gar nicht im objekt andere
große verblendet sei brauche ich auch so
dass die leute effekt von vorne getragen
eigentlich genau die gleichen geblieben
auch gut drauf haben voll krankenkassen
her aber es einfach so hätten die
probieren gegensätze foto nachzustellen
ich muss sagen ich jahren schon klar
errichtet welche auf der ems chemie
holding der familie auch aber er sieht
sogar schon er ist kraft also häufig und
sein menschlicher folgen jemand hat 80
prozent menschen weniger genau gleich
aus er rede live doch meist ist es etwa
in berlin sogar auch noch einmal ja eine
gewisse ähnlichkeit bisher so anschauen
aber ist mehr normal anderes futter
familien dass sich die frage wer
genommen wird okay bei dem regen kommt
ja auch keinen vor des körpers
entwickeln so super ist deutlich wähler
sich zufrieden wir müssen noch ein
höheres spende über das video hier
beenden sowie tages- oder fotos von mir
und meinem bruder gespeichert wir
beginnen nicht mehr so während ich mir
endlich okay doch ja doch ganz so weit
also sie findet im vergleich anders wie
das aufgenommen ist der folge
ein bisschen ist schon als gesichert
sich aber fünf kann man machen wir mal
ein anderes foto formieren das hier ein
bisschen böser als solcher zeugen zuerst
nicht gekommen
integrations und müssen ja irgendwie zum
mega bekannt aber lukas meinen verein
keinen super bekannten aliens promi für
jedenfalls mächtig ja doch also der auch
schon etwas buschige augenbrauen habe
ich einen längeren gesichert ernst oder
neben bruder supermacht mikrofon und
nehmen das foto von mahdi den ok das ist
krass oder
dass sebastian der gleiche typ kommt bei
mir das spricht dafür ist mir recht
ähnlich aus
das virus verbreitet sich mein bruder in
gewisser weise ähnlich und prosa damit
haben wir nicht gerechnet hätten also
sollte ich würde sagen ja und die
doppelgänger von einigen youtube an den
kunden wenn euch das video gefallen hat
das gerne ein leichter als ich gesehen
habe fragte auch ein video hochgeladen
die lustigste siri fragen vorgestellt
und irgendwie hat noch niemand
angesprochen
das wird nicht besser wenn ihr noch lust
hat aufweisen wie schlecht ab wir sind
zwar nicht fehlen